cavitation in a beer bottle 82 000  frames a second when the Mallet hits the  top of the bottle it causes the entire  bottle to drop down with such inertia  that the water is left behind this  sudden drop in pressure in concentrated  areas causes the water to turn briefly  to Vapor tearing open these voids called  cavitation and as soon as the water is  able to overcome the low pressure of the  cavitation bubbles each bubble slams  back closed causing a very small point  of intense heat and a Shockwave powerful  enough to smash the bottle open  everything you saw between the hammer  hitting the bottle and the glass  cracking occurred in just five  milliseconds